E aí
[Música]
Oi bom dia boa tarde boa noite
hoje eu vim aqui para contar para vocês
uma história e fazer uma pergunta a
sustentabilidade da Amazônia EA 10
carbonização das cidades Qual a relação
dá para contar essa relação eu vou
contar um pouquinho da minha história
para vocês
em 2003 eu cheguei na Amazônia
eu conheci o potencial dessa região
conhecer sua a gente as suas pessoas a
sua Flora Só falam
como resultado disso comecei a trabalhar
com açaí
Oi e a partir daí comecei a trabalhar no
futuro da Amazônia
e com todas as minhas fotos
já falaram para mim que era impossível
fazer com que eu ribeirinhos pudessem
certificar seu açaí orgânico
internacionalmente mas eu fui para
dentro do mato com muito amor e carinho
assim nem eles e eles contou seu esforço
conseguiram
E logo depois conheci pessoas entrar em
aves alguns que eu perdi nessa pandemia
a minha saudade para o Morais amiga do
coração que eu perdi uns há pouco tempo
pessoas que estiveram 35 anos
pesquisando em Como transformar embalou
o potencial da Amazônia
o ensinando a pessoas humildes mas como
um coração grande a como transformar o
que pode ser pobreza essa Henrique essa
mas não são monetária senhor espíritos
e esse ribeirinhos estão hoje lá com um
pouco do conhecimento que cada um de nós
deixou lá
é um momento
eu entendi que todo o seu esforço dentro
daquela Floresta seria inútil
é porque as cidades eram problema
a cidade São aquelas que demandam tudo
aquilo que a floresta destrói
e foi então que eu conheci um gênio que
acabou sendo quem com quem que percorri
o mundo inteiro
nos em jamais Almirante quebrado a minha
história na alça com ele começou a já
por desde ontem quando eu pedi a Deus
que me mostrasse o caminho que me
pergunte se algum dia voltar para a
floresta com uma solução
e é aquela época já começávamos a
estudar como transformar a bateria no
coração do futuro
como fazer com que a nossa companhia
mudasse a realidade não são Nossa de
todos
um
Chegamos nos Estados Unidos com muita
umidade e mostrar o que a gente tinha
como solução na época passamos vários
filtros no ano Federal não vai lá na
Califórnia na Universidade da Califórnia
e foi lá onde a gente ficou a Califórnia
viram a nossa casa
e foi então que nós começamos a
pesquisar no lugar qual era a solução é
um lugar que tinha 22 anos de legislação
em relação com a sustentabilidade das
cidades
um grande caminho percorrido do qual
precisamos aprender mas também ao qual
podemos contribuir com nova tecnologia e
maior inovação
e esses anos todos aprendemos como que
nós podemos fazer para que a cidade
descarbonizada acontecesse mas se o
problema continuar sendo mais ou menos o
mesmo
assim como Amazônia não podia ser salvo
pelos Amazonas
e a cidade não podia ser salva pelos
seus cidadãos até não ter o conhecimento
necessário e a consciência de que a
natureza precisa ser preservada para que
nossa vida nesse planeta possa conseguir
ter uma sustentabilidade no tempo e
nossos filhos e nossos netos têm um
lugar onde viver
e
foi lá que nós começamos a pesquisar
como fazemos desde o ponto de vista
tecnológico
e para que a realidade da cidade fosse
tão diferente que nós pudéssemos
respirar um ar puro que impedisse que 10
milhões de pessoas ao ano morressem pela
qualidade do ar
e essa realidade Só podia ser mudada com
cambio cultural
apoiado na tecnologia e Foi nisso que a
gente trabalhou até chegarmos onde
estamos hoje
e no ano de 2018
nós conseguimos e mostrar-te veículos
podiam comprar energia de carregadores
que os carregadores podiam comprar
energia de painéis Solares e que tudo
isso podia acontecer Sem intervenção do
homem
e a tecnologia nos fez possível o que
parecia impossível mas sempre as ideias
são precursores da Inovação EA
tecnologia ela segue a liderança do
pensamento do homem
nós pegamos um ponto no qual começamos
aplicar essa tecnologia
e nos convencermos com um grupo de
outras empresas e organizações com
moderna de com a lishan como o caminho
de tele crise de como Califórnia ele tem
bateria para que nós pudéssemos chegar a
propor o que a gente chamava de avance
energia comes in
a essas
comunidades de energia avançadas não são
outra coisa que é as nossas casas se
transformando de consumidoras em
prossumidores de sou de mandar energia
ali mandar e puder entregar
o que não são os veículos passassem a
ser elétricos compartilhados conectados
e autônomos
o que nós pudéssemos reduzir a
quantidade de veículo na rua em algum
momento e aqui há 10 15 e 20 anos a 90
porcento menos do que hoje nós temos nas
nossas cidades
e agora imagine vocês como isso pode
mudar nossa realidade
bom e você vai dizer e como que nós
chegamos em volta na Amazônia
Ah pois bem
nós conseguimos com um grupo de taxistas
da cidade de Belém gerar um projeto que
vai transformar os táxis da cidade de
Belém elétricos nos próximos meses
É isso aí é só o início de um programa
muito maior que levar à geração de
energia a conectividade e os motores
elétricos a cada um dos ribeirinhos da
Amazônia
e
essa energia vai nos permite que eles
tenham conectividade essa conectividade
vai permitir que ele tem a educação
os coelhinhos que são os guardiões da
Amazônia
aqueles que são os melhores para
defender a sustentabilidade da floresta
aqueles que conseguem dar o valor árvore
em pé mais do que a árvore no chão agora
serão educados
terão a geração da sua própria energia
terá uma fonte de renda justa a partir
da venda dos frutos daquela Floresta que
eles foram proteger a
e esse sonho que nós tivemos há tanto
tempo atrás
que meu amigo Morais não conseguiu ver é
aquele sonho que eu pretendo viver para
que ele veja lá onde ele estiver
assim foi como uma jornada que começou
na cidade grande que chegou na Amazônia
que foi uma cidade ainda maior está
voltando para a Amazônia para que a
realidade de todos nós seja diferente